- More than 72% of children
in the African American
community are born
out of wedlock.
That means absent fathers.
- 72%.
- Well.
- What does number say?
- Well, that's basically
from the '90s, no '80s.
- No, this is a 2010
government statistic.
- I don't believe that.
- You don't believe that?
- 'Cause a lot of fathers
- Do you think it's
higher or lower?
- About 71%.
(laughter)
- You just went from 72 to 71.
He was always there with us
and he was always my hero
no matter what, you know.
- Charles.
- I think that's important.
- Well, I think it's a
kind of common story,
which is my dad
- [Man] Common's story?
(laughter)
- Not Common's story,
but a common story.
- A lot of people don't
know Common's last name
is actually Denominator.
(laughter)
Is it because black
women are too bossy?
(laughter)
- I love black women.
(applause and cheering)
I want my tea.
- You don't think black
women are too bossy?
- Gimme my tea, I'm not
getting involved in that.
I am not getting involved
in that, oh my God!
- Hey America,
Larry Wilmore here.
If you like The Nightly
Show on Comedy Central,
like us on Facebook, too.
Just don't poke me, I
do not like being poked.
You can Candy Crush me.